I've been telling you for weeks and
months that as the pressure mounts
around Donald Trump he will become more
erratic and desperate and panicked and
the public-facing expression of this
panic is very likely to be tweets
endless tweets tons of tweets and we're
seeing it Donald Trump tweeted 82 times
on Saturday 82 times this makes his
tenth we trance of six months ago seem
comparatively sane and sober now what is
triggering Trump impeachment including
the public impeachment inquiry hearings
starting tomorrow which will be
streaming live on our YouTube channel
the continued incompetence and
corruption of the people around Trump
including Rudy and Sean Hannity and many
others
Trump realizing but tens of millions of
people want him out and they want him
out now Trump has been heavily triggered
and we're gonna look at a few of those
tweets shortly we're not going to look
at anywhere close to 82 but some of the
themes insult include insulting House
Intelligence Committee Chairman Adam
Schiff tweeting about him 11 times Trump
of course likes the claim presidential
harassment against himself but tweeting
11 times about one congressman it sort
of sounds like presidential harassment
by the president rather than of the
president the whistleblower mentioned
eleven times some version of impeachment
mentioned nine times let's take a look
at some of trumps tweets a lot of them
were actually retweets of various Fox
News segments that Trump determined are
favorable to him sometimes they featured
Sean Hannity or others then there were
actual tweets that Donald Trump wrote
like for example quote but the witch
hunt continues after three years of
relentless attacks against the
Republican Party and me the do-nothing
Dems are losers for America one tweet
was filled with nicknames Trump saying
quote I recommend that nervous Nancy
Pelosi who backed up shifts ly shift the
Adam Schiff sleepy Joe Biden and the
whistleblower who miraculously
disappeared after I released the
transcript of the call the second
whistleblower who also disappeared and
the IG be part of the list another tweet
about the whistleblower and witch-hunt
saying quote whatever happened to the
so-called Informer to whistleblower
number one seems to have disappeared
after I released the capital-t
transcript of the call shouldn't he be
on the list to testify witch-hunt and
then of course the old stalwart
presidential harassment in all capital
letters which his followers just love
that one getting a hundred and twenty
five thousand likes this is a tiny
fraction of what Trump did just on
Saturday eighty two tweets how does he
have this much time I mean I guess he's
barely doing anything else and maybe
that's a good thing but aside from the
content of Donald Trump's tweets which
are particularly embarrassing and
erratic one would never imagine that a
president would have time to tweet 82
times in one day about anything if you
take the job seriously and you read
briefings and history and nonfiction and
do all of the things that many other
presidents have done you don't have time
for this stuff now as much as Barack
Obama read and researched by the way he
still made mistakes on the job so how
does Trump even possibly stand a chance
if he spends his days tweeting and of
course once again is the drug issue in
the background of this this type of
manic over-the-top behavior also common
among abusers of stimulants Donald Trump
according to some who were behind the
scenes on The Apprentice snorts adderall
he's been pictured with a stack of
sudafed in his desk at Trump Tower which
can also be crushed up and used in ways
similar to a Dalal adderall tweeting 82
times in a day is another sign that is
making people wonder about stimulant
abuse because it is not normal behavior
never mind by the way that he says he
only sleeps four hours per day and often
is tweeting in the middle of the night
more signs of stimulant use or maybe
better said abuse of stimulants make
sure you follow the david pakman show on
Instagram for continued coverage of
Trump's tweets at David Pakman show
while you're there I ask you humbly
follow me on Instagram as well at David
Pakman today's program brought to you in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman
blinkie's
is a great service that I use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/p a que mas